peter baier erst koordinator für die
transatlantischen beziehungen
zusammenarbeiten des auswärtigen amtes
und unsere kollegin patricia klar hier
dabei wir haben es jetzt gerade gehört
die transatlantischen beziehungen es ist
natürlich besonders wichtig für diese
wäre jetzt gewinnt wie es jetzt in den
nächsten vier jahren weiter geht und man
stellt sich die frage für deutschland
gibt es da einen der beiden kandidaten
der eindeutig besser wäre ich formuliere
dass man ohne einen namen zu erwähnen
das ist derjenige natürlich
wünschenswert der erstmal der
internationalen beziehungen erkennt dass
er starke partner braucht und dass die
usa auch so stark wie sie sind als
militärische und ökonomische supermacht
auch angesichts auch herausforderung der
welt und veränderung ist nur china und
einige andere dinge
das nicht alleine schaffen die brauchen
starke partner wir europäer waren auch
starke partner
also das wäre jemand der gewinnt der das
erkennt der mit uns gerne
zusammenarbeiten will
herbei ich würde gerne einmal über das
sprechen was wir gerade eben gehört und
gesehen haben nämlich die
pressekonferenz in nevada sie kennen
regional den ehemaligen us-botschafter
in berlin der auch hierfür klare ansage
gesorgt hat wie haben sie das
wahrgenommen die pressekonferenz der
dort gehalten hat wohl gesagt hat wir
haben hier ein großes problem denn es
habe tote gewählt er hat menschen und es
wurden menschen präsentiert die gesagt
haben wir durften nicht wählen kann es
sein dass die öffentliche meinung der
völlig schief liegt die ja sagt der
tramp spinnt was will da jetzt
eigentlich wenn man sich das mal anhört
die kommentatoren oder haben die
republikaner möglicherweise punkt wir
haben ist fast egal ob republikaner oder
demokraten irgendwelche punkte
vorbringen derjenige der was vor bringt
das soll es auch sagen und soll dann im
zweifel dann wenn das nicht abgeschaltet
werden kann mehr irgendwelche
unregelmässigkeiten dass der weg zu den
gerichten offen und das wird dann
gerichtlich entschieden
ich will nicht ausschließen dass es
unregelmäßigkeiten gibt bei einem bei so
vielen weit über 100 millionen wählern
die abgestimmt haben
ich kann das von hier aus nicht
beurteilen das ist jetzt mal konkret
bleibt also wenn jetzt tatsächlich tote
dort gewählt haben
dann muss das doch konsequenzen haben
oder
ja ich sag ja dann geht man zum gericht
das wird festgestellt überprüft bisher
ich habe gleich selber nicht von ready
pressekonferenz erfolgen können ich habe
mir sagen lassen ich nehme meinen
mitarbeitern auf dem weg hierhin in
verbindung sagte weiter da nicht
vorgelegt das waren jetzt behauptungen
das waren worte aber die muss ja auch
nicht uns vorlegen sondern wenn dann den
zuständigen behörden und sie kennen ihn
ja sieg in kriens
haben sie das gefühl wenn er so was sagt
dann stimmt das verstehe ich bin bisher
nie in eine gerichtliche
auseinandersetzung mit der ich gekommen
das werde man sehr gutes persönliches
miteinander wirklich gut
zusammengearbeitet wir sind ja ungefähr
zur gleichen zeit damals unsere
jeweiligen ämter berufen worden
das war eine gute zeit miteinander jetzt
ist nicht mehr da also ich hab ich habe
keinen zweifel an den worten aber ich
bin nicht die instanz die das jetzt
wieder überprüfen wo es ja da gesagt ich
glaube er stand in las vegas irgendwo
vor der kamera vor den mikrofonen hat
das gesagt und das muss dann jetzt
seinen weg nehmen und dafür ist es da
ich bin nun mal darauf hinweisen der
ausstellungs prozess ist noch nicht
gestoppt das ist wir haben noch kein
ergebnis ist offen
und deswegen muss man abwarten wenn wir
noch mal zurückziehen beziehungen kommt
vor allem von den usa zu deutschland in
ihren augen was sind jetzt die
wichtigsten punkte die sobald der neue
alte präsident fest steht noch einmal
intensiver besprochen werden müssen in
der wirtschaft aber auch themen wie
klimaschutz beispielsweise ja das sind
natürlich themen auf der ein breites
themen portfolio auf der
transatlantischen agenda wird das
abkoppeln von dem was jetzt intern in
den usa sicherlich zu machen sein wird
weil man international unterwegs so joe
biden hat gesagt er möchte die
internationalen organisationen wieder
stärken er möchte das pariser
klimaabkommen wieder unterschreiben und
so einige andere dinge mehr wenig leer
abkommen mit dem iran und so weiter aber
wichtig ist glaube ich dass die usa
erkennen egal jetzt im oval office sitzt
das ja dass man ich dachte das vorhin
schon mal deswegen betont ich nochmal
starke partner dass man sich gegenseitig
braucht und da sind wir bei den von
ihnen angesprochenen handels und
wirtschaftsthemen wir haben in den
letzten vier jahren die erfahrung machen
müssen dass dort wenig unterschieden tat
zwischen freund und feind der hat seit
die europäer sogar als fonds als gegner
bezahlen wir deutsche feinde für 320
müssen sie ihn fragen ich empfinde mich
nicht so die amerikaner sind unsere
wichtigsten engsten partner außerhalb
europas und da rede ich jetzt nicht mehr
das weiße haus mir sind die menschen
willen ist das land und leute die ich
nie
viel wichtiger als das über washington
dc politische sozusagen universum also
wie sie jetzt mal ehrlich hand aufs herz
wie sie hoffen sie dass joe biden will
ich versuchen herauszukitzeln ich habe
meine persönliche private meinung wenn
sie sich nicht einmal als person
einladen und sage ich ihnen das auch den
vertrieb der du bist ja auch seit drei
tagen jetzt mit uns hier im oval office
und man hat immer wieder ein neues
gefühl dafür gehabt erst sah es aus als
würde es doch machen tatsächlich dann
jetzt joe biden so kurz vor der
schusslinie
bis zur jetzt im gefühl so dass man sagt
das ding ist eigentlich gelaufen oder
hast du jetzt so viel dazu gelernt dass
man bis zuletzt eigentlich zu tun ja ich
glaube dass das learning jetzt aus den
vergangenen stunden dass man einfach
nicht ich war es gab zeitweilig ganz
klar überzeugt rampe das ding gemacht
sieht es wieder ganz anders aus ich
möchte aber einmal auch noch nachhaken
ich auf etwas im und diplomatische weise
ist hier das jetzt getan nun einmal so
auf diese pressekonferenz auch noch mal
kommen sie sagten so ich habe da keine
zweifel erst mal dran wenn man so etwas
hervorbringen
dann steht das erst mal so im raum ich
war schon sehr irritiert dass mr green l
dort beispiele von zwei wlan
hervorgebracht hat die offenbar nicht
wählen konnten
das vorhin gesagt einer es wird von
todesfällen die dann trotzdem
registriert werden und da war eine dame
die wurde offenbar so wird es behauptet
aktiv davon abgehalten und vorher wurde
lange darüber gesprochen dass man keine
fragen also keine fragen keine antworten
kriegt aus nevada und mich hat schon
aktivität bei dieser pressekonferenz das
als diese beiden beispiele das waren
zwei menschen die dort standen und davon
berichteten dass sie nicht wählen können
das dann auf dieser pressekonferenz
keine fragen zugelassen worden also ich
finde wenn man zwei fälle hervorbringen
und sagt hier haben wir zwei fälle die
eben genau weil sie unsere einzige
bisher hab hafte untermauerung dessen
sind was wir bisher einfach nur
behaupten das müssen wir festhalten
bisher sind das völlig haltlose
behauptungen nur weil eine briefwahl
vonstatten geht kann man jetzt nicht
behaupten
es fliegt vor ort vor das heißt wenn das
quasi zwei handfeste beweise h sind die
wir haben und dann wird in einer
pressekonferenz werden keine fragen
zugelassen
irritiert nicht national ist das
zutiefst
man kann nicht den vorwurf aussprechen
der fahrer lässt uns lässt uns keine
fragen stellen
wir möchten ein blick haben wir vermuten
dass was schief läuft weil wir die
einblicke nicht bekommen dann eine
pressekonferenz geben und exakt das tun
das hat mich sehr so stimmt es doch ein
bisschen habe weiß ich nicht aber ich
will ganz klar betonen dass ich jeder
wähler der sich hat registrieren lassen
der gerne reden möchte soll das auch
können
und wenn es da um regelmäßigkeiten gibt
dann ist das zu monieren an den dafür
vorgesehenen stellen ich fasse das jetzt
von regional so auf dass er an die
öffentlichkeit herangetreten ist
sicherlich in enger abstimmung mit
donald trump die beiden sind ja dicke
buddies auch dann ist das ist ist das
etwas was man zunächst zur kenntnis
nehmen aber das war ein statement an die
öffentlichkeit
das war ich rein informatorischen und
ich habe das wie gesagt gar nicht
mitgekriegt ist es da keine fragen
zugelassen wurden aber demokratische
rechtsstaatliche grundsätze müssen
gelten wenn das jetzt zwei fälle in dem
in dem bereich sind so wenn es zwei
fälle sind wird das die den wahlausgang
nicht ändern aber aus sicht des
einzelnen wie das des bürgers ist
natürlich ein wichtiges recht dass jede
einzelne wahrnehmen können wenn sie
jetzt das gesamtbild sehen letzte frage
was glauben sie wielange müssen wir
jetzt hier noch im oval office aus
haaren wird aber was glauben sie wann
sitzt endlich jemand dort an dem sessel
hier bei uns und james joyce
ich hoffe bald und zwar im sinne der
amerikanischen bürger sollen angeblich
früh über das mal schauen und wir haben
ja also in pennsylvania wird ist wir
müssen ja wirklich gebracht bis die
fristen abgelaufen bis wirklich alle
stimmen ausgezählt ist dann wird es ein
belastbares endergebnis geben während
wir hier sitzen kann sein dass nevada
und georgia schon ausgezählt werden wir
rechnen eigentlich stündlich minütlich
fast hier nach deutscher zeit damit dass
diese ergebnisse kommen und da muss man
ja die mathematiker machen sobald 270
wahlmänner wahlfrauen zusammen sind bei
wem auch immer ist das rennen genossen
chancen
im moment sieht es so aus als werden der
vorsprung von joe biden doch sich
festigt wir müssen jetzt die ganze sich
dass die augen auch richten auf twitter
vor allem wenn es um den amtierenden
präsidenten geht und deswegen wollen wir
ihnen jetzt den neuesten tweets direkt
einmal zeigen
[Musik]
dort eine ziemlich klare und kurze
ansage die jetzt vor wenigen minuten
erst gemacht hat schon recht nur das ist
ein ausrufezeichen und dann schauen wir
müde nach diesen langen wahlkampf
arbeiten kurz nach der pressekonferenz
also wo einer seiner engsten vertrauten
darüber gesprochen hat dass in nevada
unregelmäßigkeiten sind unterstützt
donald trump jetzt die ganze sache noch
mal mit so einem tweet und da möchte ich
auch wissen aus politischer sich wie
fühlt sich das an wenn ein
staatsoberhaupt vor allem des
mächtigsten landes der welt eigentlich
ständig twitter so genutzt und vor allem
jetzt in dieser wahl immer wieder die
menschen an heiz wir haben gesehen seine
supporter ziehen auf die straßen vor
lokale und solche tourismus ansagen
macht die situation nicht besser vor
allerdings ändert sich auch nicht wenn
die stimmen sind ihr abgegeben ich weiß
gar nicht was er damit nur erreichen
will das ist auch wirklich etwas
irritierend streiche etwas das ist
einfach schlicht irritierend dass also
eine noch amtierendes staatsoberhaupt
des mächtigsten landes dieser welt also
der mächtigsten echtes person dieses
planeten
während eines noch nicht abgeschlossenen
wahl auszählung vorgangs das in die welt
raushauen was will er damit erreichen
was sie damit erreichen kann es
höchstens dass er sie hätten es erwähnt
dass menschen auf die straße gehen ich
hoffe dass das friedlich noch bleibt
wenn das aber so weitergeht ist es ja
nicht auszuschließen ist dass ich an
heißt das ganze sollte er das wenn man
dringender rat was ich sonst nicht mache
aus dem ausland dass du machen aber
police berlin
das stimmt vielen dank geht dabei dass
sie heute abend hier bei uns in unserem
berliner office waren
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bild schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren